mato grosso which means thick forest is
a state in central brazil twice the size
of California and better known today for
its endless fields of crops and cows but
there's still a lot of tropical forest
left including in Campo Norvell de Paris
a 15,000 square kilometer indigenous
reserve it's here that we meet a
Reynaldo sukhasana a key leader of the
National Indigenous Farmers Association
like most tribes the para seas used to
live from subsistence farming but now
they're growing and selling soy and
other grains for export our pregnant
women were losing their babies from lack
of food children were malnourished but
after 15 years of producing grains our
lives have changed now we have lots of
food we have 40 university graduates in
law medicine agronomy teachers all
working inside our community the project
is giving us sustainability Rinaldo and
his tribe who earlier this year received
a visit from the agriculture and
environmental ministers are the role
model for President Jade Ball scenarios
vision for integrating Brazil's
indigenous communities into mainstream
society the project has been vilified by
other indigenous groups and many
environmentalists who argue that they
will lose their culture and further
destroy the Amazon
now the disagrees we are in the 21st
century the colonial period is over all
societies transform and develops and we
indigenous peoples are also transforming
ourselves of course our culture
traditions and identity are important
but we can't remain frozen in time
indeed these days this traditional palm
leaf house is used mostly for meetings
guests and religious ceremonies
Ronaldo's mother still weaves ceremonial
clothes but now the sake Myakka family
lives in a hamlet of modern houses
outside of the reserve the president is
also giving the green light to expand
Brazil's agricultural frontier this for
example is cotton in fact almost
everything that's profitable grows here
Brazil is already the world leader in
soy and sugar cane in beef and among the
top three corn producers but in order
for the agribusiness to continue to
expand it needs more and more land which
explains why the Brazilian Amazon is so
coveted results largest soy producer
blight or modulus nevertheless concerned
nicknamed the king of soy he was given
the golden chainsaw award a few years
ago by environmentalists but today he
says unlimited deforestation of the
Amazon is unacceptable especially since
it's unleashed a global backlash tomato
Presidente keep the president has taken
a mistaken approach but I think our
mistakes in the agribusiness sectors
concerns of a possible boycott against
our products may make them realize while
the amazon is sovereign brazilian
territory it's also needed by the entire
world
londo accuses many foreign governments
of expecting indigenous tribes to remain
naked eating ants in the forest he
explains they're using only 1.7 percent
of their territory to grow soy and other
grains for export he insists they don't
need more at least for now to see a
Newman al-jazeera campin ovo de perak
sees Brazil